can we actually step back a little bit
on definitions because you said that
some of the ideas practically that
you're playing with is democratic
socialism
we talked about the higher level the
higher kind of vision of socialism the
ideals the philosophical ideas
but how does it all fit into the big
picture historically of ideas of Marxism
communism uh and socialism as as it was
defined and experienced and implemented
in the 20th century so what's your key
differences maybe even just like
socialism communism yeah well I hate the
no true Scotsman sort of response to
this which is oh that socialism is bad
so it wasn't really socialism and my
socialism is good so it is socialism
um but I think that socialism and
communism share a common ancestor which
is they both emerged out of the turmoil
and development of late 19th century
um capitalism and the fact that there
was all these workers parties that were
organizing across the capitalist World
um so in Europe for instance
you had this Mass party called the
German Social Democratic party
um in the uh that became probably the
most important the most vibrant party in
Germany in the 1880s and 1890s but they
were locked out a power because Germany
at the time was was still mostly a
Target you know it had a parliamentary
democracy but it was a very
undemocratic democracy the Kaiser is
still still ruled these movements took
Route across uh the capitalist world but
including in Russia and in conditions of
illegality
so it was assumed for many many years
and the workers movement across Europe
and among socialists of Europe they call
themselves social Democrats then
that
the revolution would first probably
happen in Germany and this developed
growing Hub of industrial uh capitalism
and not in semi-futal Russia
but then World War one came the workers
movement was split between parties that
decided to either keep their head down
or to implicitly support the war
um and then you know support the war for
now or keep your heads down don't get
banned don't get arrested then we'll
just take power after the war is over
and those like Russia and also in the
United States for that matter they chose
the path of resistance to the war
and it was the Bolshevik faction of the
the uh of the Russian movement
um but Landon's Bolshevik party that
took power in Russia after a period of
turmoil where it didn't seem well was it
going to go to the fascist right or was
they going to go to the far left there
was a period of flux and turmoil in in
Russia but definitely the old regime was
not able to to stand and these Russian
social Democrats these Bolsheviks
said social democracy has so betrayed
the idea of internationalism and
Brotherhood and progress it was supposed
to stand for that we can't call
ourselves social Democrats anymore we're
going to go back to this old term that
Marx used we're going to call ourselves
communists
and that's where official kind of
Communism out of Russia emerged in other
parts of Europe parties were actually
able to take power some in the interwar
period but most in the post-war period
And they also came out of this old
Social Democratic movement and these
parties mostly just call themselves
socialists and a lot of them still on
paper wanted to go beyond capitalism but
in practice they just manage capitalism
better in the interests of workers
um but they all had the same common
ancestor
and in practice to me social democracy
means trying to insert doses of
socialism within capitalism but
maintaining capitalism communism meant
this attempt to build a socialism
outside of capitalism and often
authoritarian ways in part because of
the ideology of these Communists but in
part because of the conditions in which
they inherited you know they were
inheriting a democracy they were
inhering a country that had been uh
ruled by the czars for you know for
centuries
um and with very little condition like a
very weak working class you know very
you know poor and devastated by War and
so on where authoritarianism kind of
lended itself uh to those conditions
um and then there's me you know then
there's Democratic socialists and the
way I would Define it is we like a lot
of what the social Democrats
accomplished but we still believe in
going Beyond capitalism and not just
building socialism within capitalism but
we believe in this ultimate vision of a
world after capitalism
what is that world look like and how is
it different from communism actually
maybe we can linger before we talk about
your vision of democratic socialism
what was wrong with Communism stalinism
implementation of Communism in the
Soviet Union why did it go wrong
so and in what ways did it not go wrong
in what ways did it succeed let me start
with the second part of that question
and that's a very difficult one to
answer in part because
I morally and ethically am opposed to
any form of authoritarianism or
dictatorship and often when you talk
about the successes of a government or
what it did developmentally that might
have been positive we have to abstract
ourselves from what we morally believe
and just just kind of look at the record
right
I would say that the Soviet experiment
started off by in Lenin's time as the
attempt to kind of just hold a holding
action
hey we don't really have the conditions
to rule this country we have the support
of the working class or most of it but
the working class is only you know three
percent of the the population you know
the peasantry is really against us a lot
of this three percent of the population
has died in war and half of them
supported the mensheviks and the more
moderate socialists anyway but
the alternative in their minds was going
to be a far-right reaction you know some
sort of General taking power in a coup
or whatever else or just them ending up
back in prison because a lot of them
were in prison on the Czar or just
killed so they figured
all right we're gonna have a holding
action where we maintain as much of this
territory of the old Russian Empire as
possible we'll try to slowly Implement
changes restabilize the economy through
something called a new economic program
which was kind of a form of social
democracy if you if you will because it
allowed market exchange for the peasants
um combined with State ownership of
Industries in the cities and
for a while it seemed to be working the
revolution never came that they were
expecting in Western Europe but in
Russia itself they were able to
restabilize things by the middle or end
of the the 1920s and they were able to
build more of a popular base for some of
their policies because people who had
seen the chaos of World War One and
Revolution and then Civil War kind of
just wanted stability and after a decade
plus of War if you had a government that
was able to give you enough to eat and a
job you know that was good enough for
them
then Stalin came into power and he
wanted to rapidly industrialize in his
logic was the revolution is not going to
come in the west we need to build
socialism in one country and we need to
catch up with the West we need to turn
ourselves into industrial Powerhouse as
quickly as possible
and that's where you got forced
collectivization to try to increase the
productivity of Russian agriculture
through State ownership of previously
fragmented agricultural Holdings and
through the
implementation of mechanization so bring
in more machines to make agriculture
more productive all under State
ownership
plus more ambitious attempts to build
heavy industry through five-year plans
now
I say this kind of coolly but we know in
practice what that meant you know forced
collectivization was a disaster I mean
first of all I think was built on the
faulty premise that scale always equals
more productivity when in fact
especially in agriculture but in any
field it's a little bit more complicated
than that and it led to millions of
deaths you know it led to famine it let
a host of other problems
um industrialization in the way that it
happened under Stalin also kind of
unbalanced the Soviet economy to lean
too heavy towards heavy industry not
enough for medium or light industry but
[Music]
this did mean especially the um The
Five-Year Plan in industrialization did
manage to put Russia on a different
developmental trajectory
so
by the time the post-war period came
the one it might have gave them the
ability to survive the Nazi invasion to
begin with it was a complicated question
and then by the time the post-war period
came uh Russia had kind of jumped ahead
of its developmental trajectory in a way
that a lot of other countries didn't do
there are a few examples like Japan is
one to manage two if you kind of ran a
scenario where Japan would be in the
1870s 1880s and ran it 100 times the
Japan of the post-war period is kind of
one of the best outcomes right and I
think that that you could say that about
Russian Economic Development its ability
to catch up at a certain level to the
West
and then after that of course um
later on
um as economies got more complex as they
kind of moved Beyond uh regular heavy
industry and as as the main stable of
the economy the Russian economy in this
command system was unable to adapt and
cope and ended up falling back behind uh
the West Again by the by the 1970s so
all this is a very long story to say
that a lot went wrong and Russia the
economic picture is actually a little
bit more complicated politically
um I I think it's just a small party
without much popular support but with
real popular sport in a couple cities
but a lot without a lot of popular
support Empire wide
um took power and they felt they
couldn't give back power
and they kept holding on to power and
eventually among their ranks in these
conditions uh one of History's great
tyrants took power and was able to
justify what he was doing
um in the context of the Russian nation
and development but also all the threats
that came from abroad through you know
the Civil War wasn't just a civil war it
was really an invasion by by many um
Imperial Powers all around the world
um as well so I think a lot of it was
conditions and Circumstance
um and I guess the the question really
is to what role ideology played was
there something within the Socialist
tradition that might have lend itself to
authoritarianism and that's that's
something we should you know talk about
and that's really complicated human
question it does seem
that the rhetoric the populism
of Workers Unite
we've been [ __ ] over for way too long
let's Stand Together
somehow that message allows
um flawed or evil people to take power
it seems like the rhetoric the idea is
so good
maybe the utopian nature of the idea is
so good that allows a great speaker to
take power
uh is it's almost like
if the mission
um like come with me friends be on the
horizon a great land is waiting for us
uh that encourages sort of yeah
dictators authoritarians to take power
is there something within the ideology
that allows for that for the sort of uh
for lying to people essentially
well I might surprise you with my answer
because I would say yes maybe but I
think that it's not just socialism
any sort of ideology that appeals to
the collective and appeals to our
long-term
Destiny either as a species or as a
nation or as a class or whatever else
can lend itself to authoritarianism so
you can see this in many of the
nationalisms of the 20th century now
some of these nationalisms used
incredibly lofty Collective rhetoric
like in in Sweden the rhetoric up we're
going to create the people's home we're
going to make this a country with
dignity for all swedes we're going to
make this a country that's more
developed more free and so on if they
manage to build a pretty excellent
Society in my estimation from that you
know in
countries like fascist Germany and Italy
they managed to do horrendous things in
Japan and horrendous things with that in
the U.S with national popular appeals uh
FDR was able to unite a nation
um to elevate
um ordinary Working Class People into a
position where they felt like they had a
real stake in the country and I think
did great things with the New Deal in
Russia of course
this language was used to trample upon
individual rights and to justify uh
hardship and abuses of ordinary
individual people in the name of a
collective Destiny a destiny of course
that was just decided by the party in
power and during the the 30s and 40s by
just Stalin himself really
um
no
I think that that that's really the case
for
making sure that we have a Bedrock of
civil rights and democracy and then on
top of that we can debate we can debate
different
um
of national Destinies we could debate
different appeals different visions of
the world but as long as people have a
say and what sacrifices they're being
asked to do and as long as those
sacrifices don't take away what's
fundamentally ours uh which is our life
you know which is our
um you know our our basic rights
and voice our voice so this this
complicated picture
because uh help me understand
you mentioned that
social democracy
is trying to have social policies within
a capitalist system
in part but your your vision your hope
for a social democracy
is one that goes beyond that
how do you give everybody a voice
while not becoming the Soviet Union
while not becoming where
um
basically people are silenced either
directly through violence or through the
implied threat of violence and therefore
fear
so I think you need to limit the scope
of where the state is and what the state
can do and how the state functions first
of all
um now for me a social democracy was
like the equivalent of
um I'll give a football analogy
um
it was the equivalent of you know
getting to the Red Zone and then kicking
a field goal you know you'll take the
three points but you would have rather
got a touchdown and for me socialism
would be the touchdown it's not a
separate different playing field some
people would say socialism would be an
interception sure sure no and they would
have they would have the right to to
again
um to say that and to say we shouldn't
go go further and most coaches would
take would take the safer out right
so you're going you're going against the
decision anyway yeah yeah but I
understand I understand so but so for
you the goal is
full socialism but I'll take the three
points of you know it's it's a part of
well I just want to March down the field
I want to get get within scoring
position the reason why um we should
really move from this analogy but the
reason why uh I call myself a socialist
is looking through
um history and these examples of social
democracy you saw that they were able to
give Working Class People lots of Rights
and income and and Power in their
society but at the end of the day
capitalists still have the ultimate
power which is the ability to withhold
investment
so they could say in the late 1960s and
early 70s
listen I was fine with his arrangement
10 years ago but now
I feel like I'm gonna you know take my
money and I'm gonna go move to a
different country or I'm just gonna not
invest because my workers are paid too
much I'm still making money but I I feel
like I could be making more I need more
of an upper hand right so their economic
power
is then
challenging the Democratic Mandate of
Swedish workers that were voting for the
Social Democratic party and we're behind
this this advance so to me what
socialism is in part is taking the means
of production right where there's
capital's Power is coming from and
making it socially owned so that
ordinary workers can control their
workplaces can make investment decisions
and so on
um now does that mean total State
ownership of everything or a planned
economy I don't think that makes any
sense you know I think that we should
live in a society in which markets are
harnessed and regulated and and so on my
main problem is capitalist ownership in
part on normative grounds just because I
think that it doesn't make sense that we
celebrate democracy and all these other
spheres but we have workplaces that are
just
treated like tyrannies
um and in part because I think that
ordinary workers would much prefer a
system in which over time they you know
crude shares in ownership where they got
in addition to base kind of ways they
got um dividends from their firm being
successful
and that they figured out how to you
know large firms they're not going to be
making day-to-day Decisions by
Democratic vote right but maybe you
would elect representatives of elected
managements
um once every year or two depending on
your operating agreement and so on
that's kind of my my vision of a
socialist society and this sounds I hope
like agree or disagree like it would not
be a crazy leap into year zero right
that this could be maybe a way in which
we could take a lot of what's existing
in society but then just add this on top
but what it would mean is a society
without a capitalist class this class
hasn't been you know individually these
people uh you know haven't been taken to
re-education camps or or or whatever
else but they're just no longer in this
position and they're now part of the
economy in other ways like they'll
probably be the first set of Highly
competent uh technocrats and managers
and and so on they'll probably be very
well compensated for their for their
time and expertise and whatever whatever
else but to me both the Practical end of
things like uh taking away this ability
to withhold investment and I'm
increasing our ability to democratically
and shape investment priorities and to
continue down the road of social
democracy and on normative grounds by
kind of egalitarian belief that that
Ordinary People should have more stake
in their in their lives in the workplace
um leads me Beyond social democracy to
socialism so there's a tricky thing here
so in in Ukraine especially but in the
Soviet Union there's the cool ox
the possible trajectory of fighting for
the beautiful message
of respecting workers rights
has this Dynamic of making an enemy of
the capitalist class
too easily making an enemy of the
capitalist class with a central
leader populist leader that says
the rich and the powerful they're taking
advantage of you
we need to remove them we need to put
them in camps perhaps not said
explicitly until it happens it can
happen overnight but just putting a
giant pressure on that capitalist class
and again the Stalin type figure takes
hold so I'm trying to understand how the
mechanism can prevent that
and perhaps I'll sort of reveal my bias
here as I've been reading a
I was going to say too much maybe not
enough but a lot about you know books
like Stalin's born Ukraine and just I've
been reading a lot about the 30s and the
40s
um for for personal reasons related to
my travels in Ukraine and all that kind
of stuff so I have a a little bit of a
focus on the historic implementations of
Communism currently without kind of an
updated view of all the possible future
implementations so I just want to lay
that out there but I worry about the
slippery slope into the authoritarian
figure that takes this sexy message
destroys everyone who's powerful in the
name of the working class and then [ __ ]
the working class afterwards
so first of all I think it's worth
remembering that the Socialist movement
had different outcomes across Western
Europe and and Eastern Europe and in
some of these countries in Western
Europe there wasn't actually democracy
before the workers move in and for the
Socialist movement so
the battle in Sweden for instance was
about establishing political democracy
establishing troop representation for
workers and that's how the parties
became popular same thing in Germany too
then it was the social Democrats who
were able to build political democracy
then on top of that add layers of
economic uh democracy
um social democracy
the Swedish social Democrats are ruled
basically uninterrupted from the early
1930s until
1976. it's kind of crazy to think about
but they were just in government they
were the leading member of government
that a few different Coalition Partners
would shift sometimes they were with
their agrarians sometimes they were with
uh the the Communists briefly but they
ruled uninterrupted and they lost an
election in 1976 and they just left
power and then they got back into power
in the 80s so so in other words like
they created a democratic system of
course with mass support of Working
Class People then they truly honored the
system because when they lost power they
lost power they left left power there's
plenty of cases like that across
um Europe and the world and in other
countries like Korea and elsewhere where
the workers movements almost militant
the most class Centric workers
um South Africa is the same way uh
created democratic systems
now Russia I think a lot of what
happened had to do with the fact that it
was never a democratic country it was
ruled by a party and the party itself
was very easy to shift from a somewhat
Democratic party in London's day to an
authoritarian one in Russia and there
was no distinction then between the
party and the state so your
authoritarian party then became
authoritarian total control over the
entirety of the state now the fact that
the Soviet system involved total State
ownership of production meant that the
authoritarianism of the party State
could go even deeper into the lives of
ordinary people compared to other
horrific
um dictatorships like pinochets Chile
and so on when maybe you could find some
Solace like just at home or whatever
else you didn't have the same sort of
totalitarian you know um uh like control
of people's lives
um but I would say that that socialism
self has yield different outcomes now in
the question of polarization
I guess that implies that this
polarization this distinction
is a distinction that isn't real in
society and that is kind of being
manufactured or generated so you mean
the capitalist class and the working
class just to clarify yeah okay so in
certain populist distinctions
the
the division is basically arbitrary or
made up the US versus them polarization
depending who the US and who the them
are you know it's it's truly a a a
something that's manufactured
but capitalism itself as a system as a
system based on class division whether
you're supported or oppose it I think
you should we should acknowledge it's
based on class division
that is the thing creating that
polarization now I think what a lot of
what socialists try to do is we try to
take bits of working class opposition to
capitalism to their lives to the way
they're treated at work and so on and
yes we do try to organize on those bases
to help workers take Collective action
to help them organize and political
parties and someone to represent their
their interests economic and otherwise
but the contradiction
exist to begin with and if anything this
system which I'm proposing Democratic
socialism would be kind of a resolution
of this this this conflict this dilemma
this thing that has always existed since
you know Chieftain and follower and and
so on we've had class division since the
Neolithic Revolution you know I think
this is a democratic Road word out of
that that tension and that division of
humanity into people who own and people
have nothing to give but their ability
to work